[Music]
what's up guys mkbhd here and welcome to
ask mkbhd number 31 for august 2018.
first things first the merch is back so
you're probably aware by now the merch
sort of comes and goes and waves but
every time we get a new wave of things
it's announced and you guys all know
when it goes on sale and we'll link it
below and everything and every time we
do this we also tend to add a couple
things i think this might be my favorite
group of things we've added yet so the
glitch shirt which you've seen in a
previous video there's also the
matte black hoodie which i've also worn
previously actually some people got mad
at me when i called it a hoodie because
it's it's technically a windbreaker or a
jacket i think all these words are fine
it has a hood so i called it a hoodie
but it's got a couple interesting things
about it mine's really wrinkly right now
but it has this little logo and it's
made of 3m material where it's kind of
really subtle but when you shine a light
at it or like take a flash photo it's
really reflective so that's pretty sweet
and it's also appropriate because
technically
summer just ended i think two days ago
was the first day of autumn so having a
little windbreaker is not such a bad
thing and then
uh one of my all-time favorites i've
shared these these matte black air pods
with you guys in the past especially on
like twitter and instagram
colorware who we worked with who
generously made these was comfortable
enough with doing a batch of them a
super limited edition batch that is now
also in the merch tour which is pretty
sick they are definitely not cheap it's
expensive to do these like hand crafted
painted air pods and get them as precise
as color where it does but they've done
it and if you're crazy enough to
actually want these well you can get
them now and last but not least is these
couple wristbands which i think are
pretty sweet i've shown these before and
there's been people asking where they
can get the bands that have worn in
videos so that's a thing now the links
below like i've said okay let's get into
the questions so obviously uh august was
a pretty incredible month for a lot of
reasons most of the questions i think
were about the elon interview or about
elon or tesla of some kind i can kind of
address some of the faqs or things you
might not know but right off the top i
can say
i mean honestly what an amazing
experience it was a lot of fun it was a
big learning experience going into an
environment like that and trying to
shoot a video again i highly recommend
watching john's behind the scenes video
where you get an idea of not just the
the gear we used and the sort of a
process that went into making that and
the rehearsal we had before but just the
the chaos of actually going into a
factory and trying to make a video there
uh i've gotten a lot of like interview
requests from news companies who want to
interview me about the interview
but what i've noticed i've declined them
all but something i've noticed is a lot
of their questions have a pretty similar
theme to them so aside from the like
typical howie's elon um obviously he was
super nice with us and very generous
with his time that he gave us but uh it
was mostly a lot of questions like why
didn't you talk about x or why didn't
you do this do x y and z so first off
this all came from or was born from a
twitter conversation which is kind of
amazing and it all when it was all
locked down and scheduled we had
scheduled 30 minutes
that was our absolute guarantee you'll
get at least 30 minutes
may or may not be more depending on how
it goes but plan to do everything in
half an hour now knowing that most of
the interviews he's done or he's had to
do like in the last year are these like
super stiff sit down interviews uh we
wanted to make this one a little more
fun so it was split into two halves
which you saw it was a sit down just
conversational half and then the sort of
a factory tour part but i have to sort
of self-time in my head getting all this
down in 30 minutes because once the 30
minutes is up it's sort of the guarantee
is over and it may end at any time so
that little notebook you saw next to me
in the interview the one on the chair
that i never once reached for during the
entire video that one that's this
notebook here that one had that i wrote
down all of my questions in it that's
one they saw me rehearsing with in
john's video i had written down all of
my pages of questions they were all on
this once we got in the interview we sat
down shook hands and started talking and
the conversation just sort of went and i
never once
never once looked at that notebook
during the talk now it was useful that i
kind of had most of the things i wanted
to talk about memorized and the
conversation actually sort of nicely
flowed between those things it's not the
same order that i wrote down but it was
cool that we just talked about tesla and
tech for a while uh but i definitely
there were a couple things in here that
i wanted to ask that i didn't for sure
so yeah for everyone wondering why
didn't ask elon what phone he carries
that's because i didn't get to it uh
although i'm pretty sure you can tell
it's an iphone like it it's definitely
an iphone so anyway yes i definitely
again recommend you watch the bts video
and now on to the twitter questions so
will you will you use the pixel 3 as a
main driver if it has that notch so i
don't know if you've been
living under a rock or just not paying
attention to any tech news but the pixel
3 xl specifically over the last like
three weeks has been leaked into
oblivion i think there's actually a full
review of the phone out already and it's
still two months away from being
officially announced like legit for real
this time google could probably just
have someone walk on stage at the event
and just go
yep
that was it and walk off stage and just
a price shows up that would just be it
but of course naturally what a lot of
people are focusing on is that gigantic
notch up at the top first of all yes i'm
going to test and use the pixel 3 and
the 3xl uh i am not a fan of the
just massive notch it seems to have but
i'm still interested in that phone
because of the camera it's going to have
a better right a better camera and
possibly an interesting better front
facing camera or camera pair than the
current pixel 2 so i'll be interested in
that uh it looks like it's keeping the
front facing speakers as well but it is
a just ridiculously ugly
horrible looking notch if the leaks are
true which they probably are did you see
this pocophone f1 what are your
impressions about the super aggressive
pricing i've read mostly information
about this xiaomi poco f1
see what they did there poco f1 and then
f phone same thing essential did you
guys have seen that already but i've
seen most of the stuff about this phone
on my timeline it's apparently an
extremely inexpensive phone snapdragon
845 six gigs of ram top-notch specs
uh under 300 bucks not coming to the us
i think it's india only for now but
bottom line yes i am interested in it i
hope to actually probably get my hands
on it soon depending on how fast that
availability happens uh but it's kind of
getting appeal the same way one plus
originally got my attention which was a
lot of bang for the buck bringing the
highest end specs you can get into the
lowest imaginable price that's like why
most people are paying attention to the
poco phone which by the way
not a good name you should have just
called it the the xiaomi f1 separate
video on the flamethrower
i don't know i
i don't know if it's work it's kind of a
is it worth a separate video
it's just a small little
it's a prop essentially it ends up
looking pretty cool on camera relative
to most other flame throwers and
i don't know i i guess i could see it
being worth maybe a short
twitter video or something like that i
don't know it's kind of needs a propane
tank and it's it's a prop right now
right now someone asked if this poco f1
is a oneplus killer again if it's only
one market right now which is just india
then i can't say it's a oneplus killer
because oneplus is in a bunch of places
and may even be coming to carriers with
the next version which is a big deal in
the us that's how you get in people's
pockets
um
but yeah it's again a lot of parallels
with oneplus i agree with that have you
ever cleaned your red sensor
no but that does kind of remind me of a
funny story so i travel a lot with
camera gear as you probably already know
and it's always in like the same couple
of think tank bags it's the the one
that's the exact size of the domestic
overhead bin it fits perfectly every
time we have this layout that we go
through i'm used to traveling with
camera stuff so what i'm also used to is
going through tsa and when i have that
bag which has all the batteries in it
and the camera body and the carbon fiber
they always see that and pull it to the
side and open it up and swab it it's
like 90 of the time but i'm flying
through these big airports like newark
and san francisco and la and usually
they just pull to the side swab it
doesn't come up with anything close it
give it back to you you're good that's
fine but a couple weeks ago or months
ago we were on a shoot where we went to
we flew into a smaller i think it's san
jose or somewhere in there a smaller
airport and so we were one of the first
flights out of there like seven in the
morning there is no one else in the tsa
line no one else in the security line
just the crew and the camera bags and
they're gonna check them they got
nothing else to do at 6 30 in the
morning at the airport if these things
go through the x-ray and they look a
little bit weird they're going to swab
them and they're going to check them but
these guys not only did they swab you
know the inside of the bag they took out
all of my lenses all the lenses in the
bag took the top of the lens off took
the body cap of the lens off and swabbed
the glass on both ends and looked
through it to make sure it was glass so
that's like five or six lenses right
there then they get to the camera and
i'm okay with all this up to this point
like i get it you're doing your job this
is what you're supposed to do but they
get to the camera the red monstro and
they're like yeah we're gonna have to
swab the inside of this and i'm like
okay wait a second
uh
no they wanted to open up the body cap
and make sure it's a sensor and swab the
inside of it and i drew the line there
but uh they did do their job and and
check the rest of our gear and
eventually we made it through that
airport but yeah that's funny that they
wanted i don't know if they
i don't know if they knew what they were
doing whatever they kept us safe the
flight was safe everything was safe what
question did you forget or regret not
asking elon
aside from the the forgetting like that
last part about what phone do you carry
uh the one regret i have is a question
which was
how did you find
these videos how does someone as busy as
elon who probably has better things to
do than watch youtube videos uh end up
watching tech videos at all land on the
channel decide that he's cool enough
with it to be on it how does that happen
do you have the youtube algorithm to
thank for that or the trending page or
just maybe he just looked for some some
phone reviews one day who knows uh would
you buy
wood joey would joy buy would you buy a
rimac
uh i would drive a rimac but that's also
like a million dollar car so i don't i'm
not gonna buy one how are you liking
your new kicks those okay so for those
who were wondering or think that was my
kicks of the day choice it wasn't to go
into that factory you need steel-toed
boots and so tesla provided still toy
boots for the whole team we weren't all
rocking the nursing home 2.0 or anything
crazy like that that was a safety
feature safety first uh how much footage
do you generally shoot for one video
the answer would vary a lot between
different video types like a review way
more typically a couple hundred gigs
closer to a terabyte but this video it's
just a lot of talking to the camera one
shot so i'll leave i'll try to put the
amount of footage this video took up
right here there you go if you could
shoot either ahri 2997 or red 2398 for a
year which do you choose how dare you
john
um it's actually you know what it's not
actually that bad
i think i would just shoot ahri 2997
that's just me i know you guys know i
love red but i also love 30 frames a
second and i could shoot ari i could
learn to shoot array for a year it's
only a year if you told me like
a lifetime
i might have other thoughts about
resolution and things like that but for
a year i'll shoot eric that's fine what
is the biggest misconception for you as
a successful content creator
that's easy uh it's the amount of work
that people think it takes to make what
we make
even at a totally different topic level
or anything else like people watch a
five minute youtube video and they
assume it took 5 10 15 minutes to make
people watch even if people watch i'd be
curious what you would think if you
watch a seven minute really well done
review of something how long you think
the process from inception to completion
took and i think 99 people would guess
way not enough time videos that we make
in tech have a writing process a
research process like this sort of a
summary process to turn it into a video
form oftentimes there's storyboarding
and shot listing and shot planning and
then you go into the actual shooting and
production phase then there's all the
editing and the post production and
everything that goes with publishing it
and distributing it
there's a lot it's not like a seven
minute video it takes an hour and i've
said it before a creative's greatest
trick is making it look easy but that
still stands today the biggest
misconception people have about
youtubers period
is how much work they think goes into it
but hey that's where i'm gonna end it
thank you guys for uh for all your
questions on twitter and for watching
this video for ask mkbhd in general to
live on hopefully uh the next one's even
more exciting but definitely stay tuned
in the next couple weeks for some of the
most exciting videos of the year on this
channel given what we just had that
should mean a little something
thanks for watching talk to you guys the
next one
peace